[Music]
today I want to talk about one of the
most important moments in recent cinema
history perhaps you remember it it went
like this
don't you know who I am I'm the geminal
[ __ ] on the geminal [ __ ] in case you
weren't spending hundreds of hours on
the internet in the early aughts this
line from the 2006 summer blockbuster
x-men The Last Stand was cribbed
straight from an amateur parody video it
inspired a wildly popular meme which
against all odds traveled from the
depths of the web to the big screen
x-men's reference to internet culture
was no mere comedic moment it was the
birth of an entirely new relationship
between Hollywood and the Internet
welcome Liz wisecrack addition on the
Mema fication of actors and no spoilers
ahead I'd guess but before we get
started want to give a shout out to this
video sponsor the new mobile game raid
Shadow legends out now on ios and
android raid is an ambitious fantasy
hero collector RPG and as you can see
the graphics are really legit
it's got PvP battles giant boss fights a
killer story and hundreds of amazing
looking heroes to collect and the best
part is it's free I've been playing it
for upwards of five hours now and I've
yet to hit a paywall there's some
tournaments coming up with both in-game
and real-life prizes so download raid
right now by using the link in the
description using our link will give you
exclusive access to 50,000 silver
immediately plus a free epic champion as
part of their new player program
courtesy of the development team so see
you there and now back to the show
this x-men thing wasn't an isolated
incident either just months earlier the
world's most prolific speaker of
profanity samuel l.jackson saw his own
fame eclipsed by a series of gifts when
his new film snakes on a plane was
announced it quickly became an online
Mia fide sensation most notably a couple
of internet fans created an overdubbed
r-rated audio trailer for the film
inspired by Jackson's role in pulp
fiction
right unable to ignore the Internet's
insatiable demand for good old-fashioned
samuel l.jackson f-bombs the film's
producers scheduled reshoots to add new
scenes that played up the ridiculousness
including the now famous line samuel
l.jackson 'he's public persona was
crucial to the internet frenzy the
incredibly salient motherfu mantra of
the film's viral bubble exploited
Jackson's firmly established on-screen
image as the potty mouth badass then two
great humorous effect it placed said bad
ass into a delightfully absurd situation
the greatest reptilian invasion in the
history of aviation fans were explicitly
waiting to see how samuel l.jackson the
celebrity entity would respond to the
scenario they were envisioning some kind
of fabricated combination of the
characters played by Jackson and the man
himself this moment represents what
we're going to call the minification of
actors while expends juggernaut moment
or snakes on a plane may seem like a
bizarre blip on our collective cultural
radar it's much more than that
encapsulating a revolutionary breakdown
in the separation between film and fan
and yet at the same time it represents
the next step in a process that's
preoccupied Hollywood's efforts since
its earliest days while the minification
of actors is new the processes that lead
up to it aren't so how did we get to
this moment a time when sad Keanu can
literally inspire the sad vengeance
seeking hero of John wick or when Ryan
Gosling is known as the face of the hey
girl meme to scores of people who have
never seen his films first we have to
understand something called
serialization but not in the narrative
sense so what is this kind of
serialization most literally a franchise
most metaphorically according to media
scholar P David Marshall you can compare
it to a series of related products such
as a car or an onscreen performance that
are stylistically linked Marshall argues
that civilization fulfilled a need of
early day Hollywood producers and help
them cement an individual movie star's
persona into the public
consciousness thus setting them apart
from the rest of the pack in the early
Hollywood star system of the 1920s
branding celebrities was an economic
strategy a way for studios to make their
films stand out in a crowded market it
was quite literally product
differentiation in a sea of attractive
movie stars cultivating demand for your
individual actors like your resident
cowboy or blonde bombshell was like
popularizing diet coke to the other
Studios soda pop and so a complex
infrastructure of public relations
professionals or magazines and studios
grew in the pursuit of molding actors
into name brands once a star became a
household name studios could then
exploit said stars fame by making the
exact same generally a serialized movies
over and over using their resident good
girl
Casanova or vamp when people got bored
actors could be cast against hype and us
consciously evoked the very same
audience expectations for example
Schwarzenegger became a brand so Studios
gave you Terminator commando predator
the running man etc tired that then they
gave you jr. and jingle all the way
where our last action hero has to fight
not with aliens but with Sinbad for a
toy with this serialization of
performances came what Marshall calls
celebrity personage personage refers to
a structure of familiarity for the
audience but also a structure of
performance for the actor in other words
a feedback loop of typecasting sometimes
that familiarity becomes so encompassing
that it literally supplants any sense of
the actor as an autonomous being when
you picture classic stars like James
Dean you picture them exactly as they
looked and behaved on-screen not their
real selves you can say the same for
Samuel Jackson who for all I know
actually goes home and soothes his
children to sleep with the common
refrain go to sleep because branded
stars equaled easy money Studios
invested in them heavily and Hollywood
celebrity personage was mediated by the
affirmation PR reps Star magazine's
agencies and more they worked in synergy
to create and safeguard celebrity
reputations back in these good old days
a celebrity name was enough to generate
reliable box office returns but that's
all
today not even heavyweights like Tom
Cruise or Jayla are totally safe fence
that's partially because celebrity
identity no longer belongs exclusively
to powerful movie executives why because
the internet it allows us to actively
participate in creating the narrative of
each celebrity giving us a scholar Paul
MacDonald writes the opportunity for an
interactive construction of star
discourse that was not possible with
previous channels of mass communication
that's changed our position in the food
chain of video according to Marshall the
audience member is now a hybrid of
producer and user that is engaged in the
media of consumption and production or a
prosumer and this fact is redefining the
dynamics of popular culture which brings
us to memes the internet meme is
comparatively more egalitarian than most
art forms it's nearly effortless to make
one anyone with an internet connection
to know how in a couple of minutes of
free time can do it and unlike literally
everything else in the culture industry
they're typically not made to generate
money they're made for the rules because
memes operate somewhat outside the realm
of economics they can actually act as an
authentic intervention in our
consumption of culture particularly
given the source material memes can pull
from literally anywhere since we have
access to literally the entire history
of American modern visual culture at our
fingertips as a result we can use beams
to evoke powerful shared moments of our
collective cultural identity and we're
doing that literally every day as a
result so much of our visual exposure to
celebrities is happening via
user-generated culture this means a more
level playing field back in the day
fandom meant passively reading canned
stories and gossip magazines or joining
a celebrity fan club today the fan can
actively shape the way they and their
entire social networks view individual
celebrities via dank memes all hail the
great prosumer but now that we have the
means to meme what are we doing with it
when it comes to celebrities three major
things first some memes are reaffirming
celebrity brands and making them even
more powerful consider the sad Keanu
mean the meme was instantly
comprehensible because it exaggerated
pre-existing notions of Keanu as phone
his life as tragic it emerged and spread
organically in June 2010 after paparazzi
published the now famous photo while the
mean began with words superimposed on
the image photo shoppers got creative
and suddenly sad Keanu was kickin it
with everyone from Stalin to The
Breakfast Club Rat Pack
at one point sad Keano was a more
popular Google search than Oprah
Hollywood had a knee-jerk reaction to
the blow-up issuing takedown notices too
sad Keano calm all right
the sad man himself expressed annoyance
about the memes characterization of him
I mean do I wish that I didn't get my
picture taken and while I was eating a
sandwich on the streets of New York yeah
but whether Keano is or isn't sad the
widespread sharing of the image has the
power to literally shape our conception
of his personage because the image of
him looking sad was serialized widely
across the internet the preconception of
his sadness confirmed and solidified
that personage until inevitably
Hollywood found a way to capitalize on
it with John wig the film and its
titular role which feels tailor-made for
Ianno casts him as a sad action hero
creating a sort of feedback loop between
his meme self and the performances he
gives sometimes memes can also
recontextualize the meaning of a
celebrity brand and tap into a larger
broader cultural sentiment that process
can be totally subconscious so let's go
back to samuel l.jackson who as
previously discussed saw his badass
personage set the internet ablaze that
to be clear the intertextual commentary
about Samuel Jackson's unique brand of
badassery is not unique to the internet
you can trace it back at least to the
days of Chappelle's Show in 2004 since
then memes have reaffirmed and
hyperbolized his persona giving the
commodified Samuel Jackson even more
value via increased recognition and
visibility but at the same time there's
an underlying explanation for why Samuel
Jackson and the particular movies snakes
on a plane captured so much Internet
attention beyond Jackson's famous potty
mouth now to go the wrong way
consider the setting a post 9/11 world
in which Jackson a beloved figure of
strength saved an airplane from attack
the perfect encapsulation of post
of an anxiety in our collective desire
to feel safe
this performance helped solidify
Jackson's badass rep which then became a
feedback loop in which Jackson was
repeatedly cast to play the character of
samuel l.jackson the actor most recently
that's landed Jackson a nine film deal
with Marvel me making isn't just a
fantastic procrastination tool it's the
paradigm shifting act of a modern
prosumer what's more our ability to make
memes ie to actively participate in
cultural production inherently changes
the way we view visual culture in seeing
movies and TV shows in part as source
material for great memes we're
developing a critical distance from the
media we consume if you've ever made a
meme you've probably experienced that
light bulb moment when you're watching a
youtube video and thought man that would
look really dope on loop in that moment
you were thinking less like a consumer
passively waiting for the next thing to
happen on-screen and more like a
prosumer searching for your next source
of inspiration in your day to day media
consumption so what does this mean for
the future of Hollywood casting and
celebrity persona well a few things
first of all it means that the cultural
currents of Internet fandom could become
increasingly visible in popular
entertainment such as the potential
Netflix heist movie announced in 2017 to
be based on this classic 2014 meme of
Rihanna and actress Lupita Nyong'o
sitting together at a fashion show
now unfortunately Danny DeVito won't be
playing detective Pikachu yet it also
means that actor identities will become
if anything increasingly reliant on the
internet masses the rapid serialization
unique to the medium of the mean means
it will continue to have the power to
create some of the key defining moments
of popular celebrity and popular culture
sometimes overnight and it will
guarantee that Bill Murray will keep
wishing you happy birthday for years to
come so what do you think our memes
creating a new class of prosumers or are
they just good for the lulz and an
upvote let us know what you think in the
comments and as always thanks for
watching guys peace
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]